Hello! Thanks for calling Mario's Pizza.
This is Carlos speaking.
Hello!
We would like a large pie with pepperoni, pineapple, and cheesy crust.
Large pepperoni with pineapple and cheesy crust?
We would also like a large pie with bacon, pineapple, and cheesy crust.
Large bacon, pineapple, with cheesy crust.
Okay. Is that gonna complete your order, sir?
You know what? Let me gauge the room.
Guys, are we gonna want another pizza?
Let me just... who's hungry?
Show of hands, let me see them.
One, two, three, keep 'em up, four, five, six.
Ah, having a party?
Yup. Pretty big one, too.
Come on, guys, keep 'em up.
Hugo? Summer? Hans? Food?
You know what, let's play it safe.
Let's get another pie with ham, pineapple.
All right, ham... oh, are you guys gonna need cheesy crust on the third?
Good question. I'll gauge the room.
Hey, guys, do we want cheesy crust on the third?
Okay, yeesh! That is a resounding yes for cheesy crust on the third.
Claire says you read her mind.